Hi, I'm Max and a work as an assistant psychologist in the Learning Disability Service in West Yorkshire. Like most people working in psychology, I'm slowly but surely working myself up to that seemingly impossible goal of getting onto the clinical doctorate. With that angle in mind, I thought I'd have a look at what's out there and see what books might be helpful for this. I came across Marianne's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, and decided that this would be a great for me to help me on my journey. I found Marianne's book really informative, most insightful. I especially liked how the stories reassured me that you don't need to be academically perfect to become a psychologist, and that as long as you have good interpersonal skills, such
你好，我是Max，在西约克郡的学习障碍服务中心担任助理心理学家。像大多数从事心理学工作的人一样，我正在缓慢但坚定地朝着那个看似不可能的目标努力，那就是考取临床心理学博士学位。怀着这个目标，我开始寻找相关的书籍，看看哪些能对我有所帮助。我偶然发现了玛丽安（Marianne）的书《临床心理学家合集》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective），并认为这对我的职业旅程大有裨益。我发现玛丽安的书内容非常丰富，见解深刻。我特别喜欢书中的故事，它们让我确信，成为一名心理学家并不需要学术上完美无缺，只要你具备良好的社交技能，比如
as compassion and empathy, you will get there. I would highly recommend this book to all aspiring psychologists, nor so those who want to know a bit more about the world of clinical psychology and maybe want to work in that field one day. What if one of the biggest mistakes we make in our careers is assuming that experience always beats fresh thinking. Because some of the most valuable things you can bring to a team may not be the things you've learned over decades. They might be your curiosity, your perspective and your ability to connect with others. In this episode, clinical psychologist Cliff Hawkins and I are taking a deep dive into soft skills and how they might just be the difference that makes the difference when it comes to psychology, work and life.
同情心和共情能力，你就一定能成功。我强烈向所有有志于成为心理学家的人推荐这本书，也推荐给那些想更多了解临床心理学领域，并希望将来能从事该行业的人。如果我们职业生涯中最大的错误之一是认为经验总是胜过新鲜思维，那会怎样？因为你能带给团队的最宝贵的东西，可能并不是你几十年来学到的知识。它们可能是你的好奇心、你的视角以及你与他人建立联系的能力。在本期节目中，临床心理学家克里夫·霍金斯（Cliff Hawkins）和我将深入探讨软技能，以及它们如何在心理学、工作和生活中成为决定性的差异。
Hi, welcome along to psychology actually. I am Dr. Marianne Trent, qualified clinical psychologist, and I'm joined by fellow qualified clinical psychologist Cliff Hawkins. Hi, Cleve. Hello Marianne. Thanks for having me. Thank you for being here and thank you. We first got chatting, I think, on LinkedIn. And it was a really interesting idea that actually whether we are to caught up in the idea of how long you've been qualified or what your experiences are and whether we should be thinking it in a different way about that? Can you tell us a bit more clear? Although it did make me think back to my NHS days and thinking if I had an assistant or trainee psychologist working with me, I'd probably be involving that person in the work, whereas because
你好，欢迎收听《心理学其实》（Psychology Actually）。我是玛丽安·特伦特（Marianne Trent）博士，一名合格的临床心理学家，今天和我一起的是另一位合格的临床心理学家克里夫·霍金斯。你好，克里夫。你好，玛丽安。谢谢你邀请我。谢谢你的到来。我想我们最初是在领英（LinkedIn）上聊天的。当时有一个非常有趣的想法，即我们是否过于纠结于你获得资格的时间长短或你的经验，而我们是否应该以不同的方式来思考这个问题？你能多讲讲吗，克里夫？虽然这确实让我想起了我在英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）工作的日子，如果当时我有助理或实习心理学家与我共事，我可能会让他们参与到工作中，然而因为
the piece of work, I was commissioned to do it independently by myself. I didn't have that facility open to me. And I do miss the opportunity to work with assistants and trainees psychologists because they bring so much more to the party. And I've always found that I learned from them, at least as much as they were learning from me. Yeah, absolutely. Just before we hit record, I was saying that one of my supervisors during my trainee years had just said, I really love it when we get trainees and when we get new assistants
那项工作是我被委托独立完成的，我没有那样的条件。我确实很怀念与助理和实习心理学家共事的机会，因为他们能带来更多东西。我一直发现，我从他们身上学到的东西，至少和他们从我身上学到的一样多。是的，绝对是这样。就在我们开始录音之前，我还在说，我实习期间的一位导师曾说，我真的很喜欢有实习生和新助理加入，
So that we've got that energy, that new influx of ideas, new ideas of things that are working in other departments that I'm not familiar with or just almost giving us that permission to push the envelope a little bit and bring that and to not think about it as just a top-down service where the knowledge is only ever imparted from above. And I guess if we've got people that might be listening in earlier in their career to think actually maybe I've got stuff that maybe I have
这样我们就能拥有那种活力，那种新思想的涌入，以及对其他部门正在运作的事物的了解，或者几乎是给了我们一种“打破常规”的许可，不要把它仅仅看作是一个知识只从上层传达下来的自上而下的服务。我想，如果有一些职业生涯早期的人在收听节目，他们可能会想，其实我可能也有一些东西，
you know, I might not be a qualified psychologist for years but I've got, you know, relatable transferable skills that these other people in the team might not have and that they might think of me as an asset. Yes, absolutely yes. Yeah, I think it is it is difficult particularly for people trying to break into the NHS because the NHS traditionally is a very bureaucratic and indeed patriarchical organization, a very old-fashioned organization in how it's built up and how it's developed. And so there can be a risk of assuming that if someone has simply been there longer than anyone else, that they must be the best qualified for a particular job. And of course, we know from the real world that that isn't necessarily the case.
你知道，我可能还没获得心理学家资格，但我拥有一些其他人可能没有的、可迁移的相关技能，他们可能会认为我是一项资产。是的，绝对是。是的，我认为这确实很困难，特别是对于那些试图进入NHS的人来说，因为NHS传统上是一个非常官僚且确实带有家长式作风的组织，在它的建立和发展方式上非常老派。因此，如果仅仅因为某人待的时间比别人长，就认为他们一定是最适合某个职位的人，这可能会有风险。当然，我们从现实世界中知道，情况未必如此。
Yeah, it's making me think about a couple of things, really, during my trainee years. And obviously if you're doing the assistant psychologist route, then you're used to knowing that you scored, you know, first or second best to be able to get that highly competitive job. And you've usually met the person who's going to be your supervisor or manager at the interview. So there's some aspect of having been, you know, hand selected and chosen. that's not usually the case if you then go on placement as a trainee. And often you are sometimes called the trainee or the trainees. And it's that idea that you don't really have an identity of your own and that you could have been a puzzle piece that's just slotted in.
是的，这让我想到了我在实习期间的几件事。显然，如果你走的是助理心理学家路线，那么你习惯于知道你必须考到第一或第二名才能获得那份竞争激烈的职位。而且你通常在面试时就已经见过你的导师或经理了。所以，这在某种程度上是被“精挑细选”出来的。但如果你后来作为实习生去实习，情况通常就不是这样了。而且你有时会被称为“实习生”或“实习人员”。这是一种你没有自己身份的感觉，就像你只是一个被塞进来的拼图块。
And I mean, I think that's really tricky. Yes. Well, it reminds me a bit of the sitcom. Amandaland where the parents at the school aren't talked about or two by their name. They're just Damien's mother or Adrian's father. They don't have an identity of their own outside being a parent. And I think as you say, the NHS is quite good at putting people into boxes and not really thinking about who people are as individuals and what they might be bringing. I think it's the idea that that you are valued and you have value and that you matter even if even if you haven't
我的意思是，我认为这真的很棘手。是的。这让我想起了一部情景喜剧《阿曼达兰》（Amandaland），学校里的家长们不被直呼其名，他们只是“达米安的妈妈”或“阿德里安的爸爸”。除了作为父母之外，他们没有自己的身份。正如你所说，NHS很擅长把人放进盒子里，而不去思考他们作为个体是谁，以及他们能带来什么。我认为关键在于，你要意识到自己是有价值的，你是重要的，即使你
necessarily been chosen for that particular role or service and empowering yourself to think well what can I learn what can I demonstrate and I think it is really tricky during training because I don't know what your experiences are like and how you've seen this play out in your own training and other people's but I certainly, when I was in my intellectual disabilities placement, I was on my third placement in my second year and very much felt I should know more. Like, I'm going out to people's homes, I'm going out to kind of residential facilities as, you know, the trainee, clinical psychologist who's going to really help them with their problems. But I had never worked in a service for people
不一定是被选中担任那个特定角色或服务的人。要学会赋能自己，思考我能学到什么，我能展示什么。我认为在实习期间这确实很棘手，我不知道你的经历是怎样的，也不知道你在自己的实习和其他人的实习中是如何看到这种情况的，但我确实在智力障碍实习期间，那是我第二年的第三次实习，我非常强烈地感觉到我应该知道更多。就像，我作为一名实习临床心理学家去人们的家中，去各种居住设施，去真正帮助他们解决问题。但我从未在为人们提供服务的机构工作过
with intellectual disabilities. And so it was really, I think, a very humbling experience because I had to just think about, I guess, my soft skills, my transferable skills. And it's very interesting to me that by the time I finished that six-month placement, the team wanted to be able to create a job for me to have me back kind of when I was qualified. Unfortunately, the timeline didn't align, as NHS jobs often don't. But that I think really did me the power of good to think, well, maybe it isn't the magic things that I might have in my toolbox that matter. Maybe I guess I'm enough and it isn't just the things I've done that make me a good enough trainee and will make me a good enough qualified psych. Well, I think you make an extremely important point there, Marian.
患有智力障碍的人。所以，我认为那是一次非常谦卑的经历，因为我不得不思考，我想，我的软技能，我的可迁移技能。对我来说非常有趣的是，当我完成那六个月的实习时，团队想为我创造一个职位，以便在我获得资格后让我回来。不幸的是，时间线没有对齐，NHS的工作往往就是这样。但我认为这对我大有裨益，让我思考，也许我工具箱里那些神奇的东西并不重要。也许我本身就足够了，不仅仅是我做过的事情让我成为一个足够好的实习生，并让我成为一个足够好的合格心理学家。嗯，玛丽安，你提到了一个极其重要的观点。
And I think it's interesting that we refer to certain attributes as soft skills. And the implication can be that they're somehow easier or less important than the hard skills. Although actually in my experience, the hard skills are easier to learn. So, for example, I've been really struggling to get a plumber. it's quite easy to get a plumber who has the hard skills, who knows how to fix taps and things like that, what I find it really difficult is to find a plumber who has certain soft skills,
而且我觉得很有趣的是，我们将某些属性称为“软技能”。这可能暗示它们比“硬技能”更容易或更不重要。尽管实际上根据我的经验，硬技能更容易学习。例如，我一直很难找到一个水管工。找一个拥有硬技能、知道如何修理水龙头等的水管工很容易，但我发现很难找到一个具备某些软技能的水管工，
such as calling me back when they say they're going to. And it might sound a trivial thing, but I'm a busy person. I don't have time to wait around for a plumber to decide when that person will come and work with me. I need someone who will come, who will work to my agenda. And so I think we often underestimate the soft skills. And the danger there is that aspiring psychologists and even qualified psychologists can neglect soft skills.
比如答应回电却真的回电。这听起来可能是一件琐碎的事情，但我是一个忙碌的人。我没有时间等水管工决定什么时候来为我工作。我需要一个会来、会按照我的日程安排工作的人。所以我认为我们经常低估软技能。危险在于，有抱负的心理学家甚至合格的心理学家可能会忽视软技能。
And I often say to trainees and assistants, the most important thing is to be reliable, which means being on time, which means keeping your promises, not arriving at 10 past 9 for a 9 o'clock meeting. It doesn't matter how many degrees you've got, people will get irritated if you're consistently late for meetings. Yeah, because it doesn't feel like you've been appropriately respected, I think. And it does get people's backs up, doesn't it? When I've worked in teams when someone's consistently late or, I guess, goes out for many, many cigarette breaks. And then other people in the team maybe don't smoke or only smoke outside of work hours. It's kind of hard to have that team harmony and resentment can build, can it, very much so.
我经常对实习生和助理说，最重要的事情是可靠，这意味着准时，这意味着信守承诺，而不是9点开会却在9点10分才到。无论你有多少学位，如果你总是开会迟到，人们都会感到恼火。是的，因为我觉得这让人感觉没有得到应有的尊重。而且这确实会让人反感，不是吗？当我在团队中工作时，如果有人总是迟到，或者，我想，出去抽很多次烟。而团队中的其他人可能不抽烟，或者只在工作时间之外抽烟。很难保持团队和谐，怨恨情绪会滋生，不是吗？确实如此。
Yes, and I think a lot of the people we work with are very disempowered. I remember watching a drama, a play that had been put on by people with intellectual disabilities a number of years ago. And it was, the play itself was of a case conference, a multidisciplinary meeting. And it started and then one of the actors came in breathlessly a few minutes later and said, oh, sorry, I'm late. I'm the social worker. And of course, everyone in the audience laughed because the stereotype was, well, the social worker will be late. And so although it was making a comedy point, it was a very serious point as well that these people with intellectual disabilities were used to not being respected at all. And although it was a
是的，而且我认为我们共事的许多人非常缺乏自主权。我记得几年前看过一部由智力障碍人士表演的戏剧。那是一场关于病例会议、多学科会议的戏。戏开始了，然后其中一名演员气喘吁吁地在几分钟后进来，说：“哦，抱歉，我迟到了。我是社会工作者。”当然，观众席上的每个人都笑了，因为刻板印象就是“社会工作者会迟到”。所以，虽然这是一个喜剧桥段，但它也提出了一个非常严肃的观点，即这些智力障碍人士习惯了根本不被尊重。虽然在那个场景中是
social worker in that scenario. In my experience, unfortunately, it could just as easily have been a clinical psychologist. Yeah, I think I probably have a natural tendency to be a bit later, but I make sure that I am not late because I was raised by a late mother and would drop me at swimming lessons. And I might be on time for the swimming lesson, but she wouldn't be on time to come and get me, because she was like, oh, I did this or I went to do this. And she kind of wouldn't stay and be present. And I was used to being dropped off to work late or being picked up from work late.
社会工作者。根据我的经验，不幸的是，那个人完全可能是临床心理学家。是的，我想我可能天生有点容易迟到，但我确保自己不会迟到，因为我是被一个迟到的母亲抚养长大的，她会送我去游泳课。我可能准时参加游泳课，但她却不会准时来接我，因为她会说，“哦，我做了这个，或者我去做了那个。”她不会留下来陪伴。我习惯了被送去工作迟到，或者被从工作地点接回来迟到。
And I don't want that to have other people have that experience of me. And I don't want my children, I guess it's how trauma works, isn't it? I don't want my children to have that experience of, oh, well, they're always late. I didn't enjoy that, you know, because when, I guess, and I guess this is interesting for reflection on clients attending services. If they are younger, if they're minors, you know,
我不希望别人对我也有这种体验。我也不希望我的孩子们，我想这就是创伤的作用方式，不是吗？我不希望我的孩子们有那种体验，即“哦，好吧，他们总是迟到”。我不喜欢那样，你知道，因为当，我想，这对于反思客户参加服务的情况很有趣。如果他们更年轻，如果是未成年人，你知道，
that doesn't reflect on them always, does it? It's often about who is bringing them. So I have to make sure that I factor in the extra time it takes to do the things that we'll often forget we have to do, like find our shoes, get our bag, make sure we've got our phone. or a charger and brush my teeth and look in the mirror to check my hair's looking all right. So I have to almost make an active decision to tack that extra bit on because it was always that bit that my mum would be late by. And I just don't want that. I'm not willing to continue to perpetuate that cycle.
这并不总是反映在他们身上，不是吗？这通常与带他们来的人有关。所以我必须确保我考虑到做那些我们经常忘记做的事情所需要的额外时间，比如找鞋子、拿包、确保带了手机或充电器、刷牙，并照镜子检查头发是否看起来不错。所以我几乎必须做出一个积极的决定，把那额外的时间加上去，因为那总是让我妈妈迟到的那部分时间。我只是不想要那样。我不愿意继续延续那个循环。
But also I'm not willing to have people hold me in mind like that. Okay. So we thought about kind of soft skills and how they might be very much underrated. Are there any other kind of bits and pieces that you think we might be overlooking, clear? Well, one of the soft skills that I think does get underestimated is, is Carpe deum sees the day. Lots of times in my career and I appreciate it helps that I've got the privilege of being white and male and sounding middle class. Lots of times I've applied for things and I've got things and I've been surprised to think, well, I was the only person apparently who applied, even though I'm sure there are other people out there more qualified. So, for example, last week I bumped into a support worker who I found out had a psychology degree and I said, okay, send me an email and I'll see what I can do to help you.
但我也同样不愿意让人们那样看待我。好的。所以我们思考了软技能以及它们是如何被严重低估的。克里夫，你认为还有什么我们可能忽略的吗？嗯，我认为被低估的软技能之一是“及时行乐”（Carpe diem）。在我的职业生涯中，很多时候，我很感激作为白人男性且听起来像中产阶级的特权对我有所帮助。很多时候我申请了某些东西，我得到了它们，我很惊讶地想，好吧，显然我是唯一申请的人，尽管我相信外面有其他人比我更有资格。例如，上周我偶然遇到了一位支持工作者，我发现他有心理学学位，我说：“好吧，给我发封邮件，我会看看我能做些什么来帮助你。”
Now I'm used to doing that and I'm used to not hearing from those people. And I always think, well, what an opportunity they're potentially missing. That I, you know, I know lots of people. I could potentially be helpful. Now, as it turned out, this particular graduate has emailed me with a very, a very, a very appropriate email. And so that will make me inclined to give that person a bit of my time. And who knows how helpful that might be? And I think often people don't have the confidence.
现在我习惯了这样做，也习惯了没有收到这些人的回音。我总是想，他们可能错过了多么好的机会。我认识很多人。我可能可以提供帮助。事实证明，这位毕业生给我发了一封非常、非常、非常得体的邮件。所以这会让我倾向于给那个人一些我的时间。谁知道这会有多大帮助呢？我认为人们往往缺乏自信。
And again, I appreciate I have multiple privileges, which perhaps have imbued me with a certain confidence that other people might not have. However, going after opportunities, not letting opportunities pass one by, I think it's a crucial skill, given how competitive we know it is to become a professional psychologist, any type of professional psychologist. Yeah, and it kind of making me think of when I work with people contact me and say, how can I, you know, get my foot in the door? And I think if someone's already working, like, as an HCA, so a healthcare assistant on a ward or doing bank work, I'm always like, well, if you're already working, you know, doing one-to-one obes or kind of regularly working with a particular client who you know is open to clinical psychology, can you start to say to the psychologists, would I be able to come into the MDT formulation
同样，我很感激我拥有多重特权，这或许赋予了我某种其他人可能没有的自信。然而，去追求机会，不让机会溜走，我认为这是一项至关重要的技能，考虑到我们都知道成为一名专业心理学家，任何类型的专业心理学家，竞争是多么激烈。是的，这让我想起当人们联系我说“我该如何迈出第一步？”时。我想，如果某人已经在工作，比如作为病房的医疗保健助理（HCA）或做临时工作，我总是说，如果你已经在工作，你知道，做一对一的观察，或者经常与你知道对临床心理学持开放态度的特定客户一起工作，你能开始对心理学家说，“我能参加多学科团队（MDT）的制定吗？”
when you're discussing this client? Because then you're getting that experience of seeing how this is applied in reality, but also that you might be able to feed in your kind of examples and insights and reflections of this person. And they might really value you that because you might be seeing things differently than they are. And it's not just that you are, trying to take from that experience. It really is that actually we think you've got really interesting insight and you might benefit our team discussions, but unless you think to kind of say that you'd be happy to do that,
当你讨论这个客户时？因为这样你就能获得在现实中应用这些知识的经验，而且你可能能够提供你对这个人的例子、见解和反思。他们可能会非常重视你，因为你看到的可能与他们不同。这不仅仅是你试图从那种经验中获取什么。实际上，我们认为你确实有非常有趣的见解，你可能会对我们的团队讨论有所裨益，但除非你想到要说你很乐意这样做，
you'd be willing to do that, that opportunity might not necessarily come directly to you. Yeah, yes, because people like you and me have got limited time and we're unlikely to chase people who might, be asking us for things. It might be necessary for people to chase us and that might make the difference. Someone who is assertive enough to, for example, send the email after after approaching me and to send an appropriate email as well, an email that makes me think, yes, this person, I think will make a good clinical psychologist in the future. So I'm prepared to put myself out to
你愿意这样做，那个机会可能不会直接来到你身边。是的，是的，因为像你我这样的人时间有限，我们不太可能去追逐那些可能向我们寻求帮助的人。人们可能需要主动来找我们，这可能就是区别所在。一个足够自信的人，例如在接触我之后发送邮件，并且发送一封得体的邮件，一封让我认为“是的，我认为这个人将来会成为一名优秀的临床心理学家”的邮件。所以我准备好付出努力去
give them some help for free. Whereas if someone either didn't email me or it was perhaps a badly written or badly spelled email, then I'd be less likely to give that help. Yeah, I think it's about making it bespoke and personalised, isn't it? So in this days of kind of AI and chat GPT, it's kind of easy to tell whether this feels like it's something that's been written by a person. And so just really empower yourself, to be yourself, to use yourself kind of as that intervention as part of the tool to get you what you want. I think it's also really important to hold in mind the idea that you're not an extra in your own life. Kind of we should be a key player, but to bear in mind that everyone else is the kind of the leading actor in their own lives. and they don't always have time to fully consider everyone else in the cast.
免费给他们一些帮助。而如果有人要么不给我发邮件，要么是一封写得很差或拼写错误的邮件，那么我给这种帮助的可能性就会降低。是的，我认为关键在于使其定制化和个性化，不是吗？所以在这个人工智能和ChatGPT的时代，很容易分辨这是否感觉像是某个人写的。所以，真正赋予自己力量，做你自己，利用你自己作为干预手段，作为让你得到你想要的东西的工具的一部分。我认为还要记住一个想法，即你不是自己生活中的配角，这一点也非常重要。我们应该是关键参与者，但要记住，其他人也是他们自己生活中的主角。他们并不总是有时间充分考虑剧组中的其他人。
And so it's kind of your job every now and they're, woohoo, I'm here and remind people, but also know that it's okay to ask to have your needs met. And then that gives people a chance to either meet them or or politely decline that opportunity. Yeah. Okay, so we're getting a really nice collection of these soft skills. Any others, Cliff? I think another one is to keep promises. For example, if I'm asked to deliver a report by a certain date, I will deliver it by that date. There's no doubting that that will happen. And thinking back to people earlier in their careers, that might mean if someone asks to receive some data from you, if you're doing some data analysis, again, get it done by when you say you're going to, because that may be your one opportunity. to impress that individual or that maybe that you'll want opportunity to surprise that individual.
所以，时不时地“嘿，我在这里”并提醒人们是你的工作，但也要知道，要求满足你的需求是可以的。然后这给了人们机会去满足它们，或者礼貌地拒绝那个机会。是的。好的，所以我们收集了一系列非常好的软技能。还有其他的吗，克里夫？我认为另一个是信守承诺。例如，如果我被要求在某个日期前提交报告，我会在那个日期前提交。毫无疑问，这一定会发生。回想职业生涯早期的人，这可能意味着如果有人要求你提供一些数据，如果你正在做一些数据分析，同样，在你承诺的时间内完成它，因为那可能是你唯一的机会。去给那个人留下深刻印象，或者那可能是你给那个人带来惊喜的唯一机会。
Sometimes when people say to me, well, yes, Cliff, I'll let you have that by a certain date. Unfortunately, sometimes I'm surprised. I'm more surprised when they do let me have it by a certain date because I'm used to people always providing things late. Again, coming back to the plumber, I'm more used to plumbers not ringing me back or not getting back to me by the date, they say, so when someone, does, it's a nice surprise. So we're not necessarily talking about who's the most intellectual person to be a psychologist. It might seem boring, but the most reliable person can actually be the
有时当人们对我说，“好的，克里夫，我会在某个日期前给你。”不幸的是，有时我会感到惊讶。当他们真的在某个日期前给我时，我会更惊讶，因为我习惯了人们总是迟交东西。再次回到水管工的问题，我更习惯水管工不回我电话，或者不在他们说的日期前回复我，所以当有人这样做时，这是一个令人愉快的惊喜。所以我们不一定是在谈论谁是成为心理学家最聪明的人。这看起来可能很无聊，但最可靠的人实际上可能是
most useful person to the people for whom we're working. Yeah, can't it just. It's reminding me that I've promised to get some quotes back to a journalist today about a certain thing. And I've I've had to add that to my own Trello board and set myself a reminder because it's important for me to be able to do that, but also I've said I'm going to do that and so I want to be able to do that. Yeah, very much so. Okay, Cliff, are there any kind of models or ways of kind of holding all of this stuff in mind? Well, one thing that I've been lucky enough to do in my career is to spend some time completely out of healthcare for a number of years working as a management consultant in industry and also as part of that time I did an MBA and although I now work primarily
对我们服务对象最有用的人。是的，难道不是吗？这提醒我，我今天答应给一位记者提供一些关于某件事的引语。我不得不把它加到我自己的Trello看板上，并给自己设了一个提醒，因为能够做到这一点对我来说很重要，而且我也说过我会这样做，所以我希望能够做到。是的，非常如此。好的，克里夫，有没有什么模型或方式来记住所有这些东西？嗯，在我的职业生涯中，我有幸做的一件事是，在医疗保健领域之外完全脱离了几年，在工业界担任管理顾问，在那段时间里我还攻读了MBA，虽然我现在主要从事临床工作，但我也会做组织工作，即使在进行临床工作时，我也会运用那种组织经验、培训和学习。例如，有一个由麦肯锡管理顾问开发的“7S模型”。玛丽安，当你谈到软技能时，你让我想起了它。对于那个7S模型，人们可以去谷歌搜索，有三个所谓的“硬S”。这就是组织拥有的战略，然后导致该组织的结构，以及使该结构能够运作的系统。那三个硬S当然都是至关重要的。
clinically I still do work organisational as well and even when I'm working clinically I bring that organisational experience and training and learning to bear so for example there's a model known as the the seven S's developed by the McKinsey management consultant. and you reminded me of it, Marianne, when you talked about soft skills. And with that 7S model, which people can Google, there are three what are called hard Ss is. And that's the strategy that an organisation has that then leads to the structure of that organization and the systems that enable that structure to work. And those three hard essays are all vital, of course.
然而，对于任何组织来说，它们都是不够的，除非组织至少对四个“软S”给予同样的关注。第一个软S是“员工”（Staff）或可以是“人”（People），在正确的时间把正确的人放在正确的位置。并确保这些员工拥有正确的技能。他们可能带着正确的技能来，或者我们可能必须培养这些技能。那么“共同价值观”（Shared Values）呢？这些人如何融入组织，或者组织如何演变以考虑新的共同价值观？组织的“风格”（Style）是什么？人的风格是什么？例如，要与我共事的人必须可靠。我对不可靠的人不感兴趣。我不想要才华横溢但不可靠的人。我想要稳重可靠的人。所以我认为记住那七个S，对于任何领导组织的人来说都是至关重要的。然而，对于职业生涯刚开始的人来说，记住这一点也很好，
However, they won't be sufficient for any organisation unless the organisation pays at least the same amount of attention to the four softesses. And the first softnesses is staff or could be people, getting the right people in the right place at the right time. And making sure that those staff have the right skills. They might come with the right skills or we might have to develop those skills. And then what about shared values? How are those people fitting into the organisation or how does the organisation evolve to take account of new shared values? And what's the style of the organisation? What's the style of the person? So, for example, someone who's going to work with me will have to be reliable. I'm not interested in flaky. I don't want brilliant flaky people. I want steady reliable people. And so I think remembering those seven s is, it's it's crucial for anyone leading an organisation. However, it's also good to bear in mind for someone at the start of their career as well,
因为我认为在我们职业生涯的任何阶段，关注那七个S中的每一个，并思考“我的优势在哪里？我能给组织带来什么？”并不需要七个都擅长。然而，我想任何拥有心理学学位的人都会擅长那七个中的一些。是的，这让我想起，这会成为一种非常好的方式，我不知道，在面试中互动，
because I think at any stage of our career, paying attention to each of those seven S's and thinking, where do my strengths lie? What can I bring into an organisation? One doesn't have to be good at all seven. However, I guess anyone with a psychology degree is going to be good at some of those seven. Yeah, it's making me think that would make a really nice kind of way of, I don't know, interacting
特别是对于那个总是有点尴尬的结尾部分，“你有什么问题吗？”或者“你还有什么想说的吗？”实际上能够展示一些软技能并使用那个模型，因为我总是认为在回答中能够融入一点理论，或者，你知道，展示你如何使用这种复杂的心理学知识是非常好的。所以我认为这对某人来说会是一个很好的建议和想法。非常感谢你抽出时间与我们交谈，克里夫。我很喜欢。
in an interview, especially for that, you know, the end bit that's always a bit awkward, have you got any questions or have you got anything else you want to say? And actually being able to demonstrate some of those softer skills and using that model, because I always think it's really nice in an answer to be able to weave in like a little bit of theory or, you know, demonstrate how you can use this complex psychological knowledge. So I think that would be a great tip, an idea for someone. Thank you so much for your time in speaking with us, Cliff. I've loved it.
我们可以在哪里了解更多关于你和你工作的信息？如果你去我的网站，你会发现博客部分有一些东西，你可能会觉得很有趣，还有一大堆其他的东西。我的网站是 www.cliffhawkinspsychology.com，全部连在一起。CliffHawkinsPsychology.com。非常感谢。我会确保在描述和节目笔记中链接所有这些内容。但再次感谢你抽出时间与我交谈。不客气。谢谢，玛丽安。谢谢。再次非常感谢我的嘉宾克里夫·霍金斯。请务必在领英上关注他。如果你对心理学职业旅程感到好奇，
Where can we learn more about you and your work? If you go to my website, you'll find some things in the blog section of it, which you might find interesting and a whole stack of other stuff. My website is www.cliff Hawkins Psychology, all one word.com. Cliff Hawkins Psychology.com. Thank you so much. I'll make sure that I link all of that in the description and the show notes. But thank you again for your time in speaking with me. You're welcome. Thanks, Marianne. Thank you. Thank you so much again to my guest, Cliff Hawkins. Please do go and follow him over on LinkedIn. If you are curious about the psychology career journeys
临床心理学家和其他HCPC心理学家，我想你会非常喜欢《临床心理学家合集》这本书。如果你读过那本书或我的任何其他书籍，如果你能考虑给我留下亚马逊或Goodreads评论，我将不胜感激。如果你自己也是一名有抱负的心理学家，并且你喜欢临床心理学家带给你的细微差别、反思和制定方案的能力，我想你会非常喜欢“有抱负的心理学家会员资格”（Aspiring Psychologist Membership），你每月只需30英镑即可加入，没有最低期限。该会员资格确实能为人们带来真正的成果。查看我关于“有抱负的心理学家”网站的谷歌评论。在录制此节目时，我刚刚有
of clinical psychologists and other HCPC psychologists, I think you are you. think you will really like the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. And if you have read that or any of my other books, I'd be so grateful if you consider leaving me an Amazon or Goodreads review. If you are an aspiring psychologist yourself and you love the nuance and the reflection and the ability to formulate that being around clinical psychologists gives you, I think you'll really love the aspiring psychologist membership, which you can join from just £30 a month with no minimum term. And the membership really does get real results for people. Check out my Google reviews for the aspiring psychologist website. At the time of recording this, I've just had the
本学年第10个人确认他们至少获得了一个临床心理学博士学位名额。所以他们将成为实习临床心理学家。我们不是一个大型会员组织，所以这是一个巨大的数字。如果你明年想处于那个位置，请考虑加入我们。没有最低期限，每月只需30英镑，我期待着支持你。如果你喜欢这一集，我想你也会非常喜欢这一集。我正在与合格的教育心理学家亚当·麦卡特尼（Adam McCartney）博士聊天，讨论工作中的幸福感，以及我们如何减少职业倦怠。
10th person this academic cycle confirm that they have been offered at least one place on the doctorate in clinical psychology. So they are going to be trainee clinical psychologists. and we are not a big membership, so that is a massive figure. If you would like to be in that position next year, please do consider joining us. There's no minimum term you can join from just £30 a month, and I will look forward to supporting you. And if you've enjoyed this episode, I think you will really enjoy this one too. I'm chatting with Dr Adam McCartney, a qualified educational psychologist about well-being at work. and how we can reduce burnout.
我想你会喜欢的。我叫亚娜（Yana），我是一名实习心理健康从业者。我读了《临床心理学家合集》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。有多少种不同的途径可以达到目标，而且没有完美的途径，这让我感到惊讶。这让我充满了信心，
I think you'll love it. My name's Yana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me of confidence that,
不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，这能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。此集暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist, I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
不，我并没有做错，也减少了对自己的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐你读读这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来了。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。